good day and welcome to the webcast
of our uncle mind world presentation
entitled
first experience with the
iron torrent genexis workflow
i'm kojo alenitova johnson i'm a
professor in the department of pathology
and laboratory medicine permanent school
of medicine at the university of
pennsylvania
by way of an outline
our presentation will include
a brief introduction and goal statement
of the
study
a principles of
iron torrent sequencing
an introduction to the genexis
instrument
i'll offer some results of preliminary
studies that we've performed using the
i'm torn genexis instrument
i will summarize
and we'll have an opportunity to
interact in the q and a session
at the end so ngs or next generation
sequencing based approaches
have dramatically transformed
the practice of genomic and precision
oncology
at the level of the laboratory and
importantly in the delivery of precision
therapies
to the right patient at the right time
however there are operational barriers
associated with ngf
implementation in routine clinical
testing
these include a long turnaround time
from receipt of a sample to results
depending on the systems that are
utilizing the size
of the genome and number of targets
interrogated
those can vary from
six
days to more than two weeks
tissue requirements have also been a
barrier
given the routine practice of pathology
involves
generation of a large variety of sample
types
including tissue biopsies frequently
fixed paraffin embedded tissue samples
associated with a decrease in the
accessible quality and quantity of
retrievable nucleic acid
this is proven to be an important
barrier
in the delivery of ngs based
molecular testing it's been expensive
relative to the singleton assays that
have been performed in the past
and that includes accounting for highly
trained
personnel the inability
or the loss
of the ability that in a cost efficient
manner
to run small sample batches
so typically
many laboratories have resorted to
batching samples
hence running
ngs based assays at
intervals that are really incompatible
with a
rapid turnaround time
and they've also been complicated
workflows and the complicated workflows
require a system where
nucleic acid isolation is separate
from the sequencing
itself and sequencing itself includes
several steps
library preparation with or without some
amplification and then the sequencing
process itself
and then the interpretation of the
sequencing data using sophisticated
bioinformatics tools
not just the tools but the personnel
overall this has represented
a significant barrier to be able to
operationalize ngs based
sequencing strategies in a manner that
is optimal
for the delivery of precision oncologic
diagnostics
so the goal of our study
was to evaluate the ease of use of the
genexis system
as a sample to result platform for the
identification of somatic variants
in cancer given the barriers i
articulated in the previous slide
additionally we sought to determine
performance characteristics
of the genexis system compared to
an iron torrent personal genome machine
based analysis of well-characterized
somatic variants
from nucleic acid from clinical samples
this is after
we had evaluated the performance
characteristics of the system
using the
acrometrics controls that are
distributed
and utilized widely
in molecular laboratories as
performance assessment controls
now iron torrent sequencing
is underpinned by
an innovative technology
which is based
on
physiological biochemistry
and then every time when a
nucleotide is incorporated
into a strand of dna by a polymerase
a hydrogen ion or you could say a proton
is released and a high density array
of micro machined wells
performed this biochemical process in a
massively parallel way
so if you imagine
beads with nucleic acids
embedded in them on which
amplification and sequencing can be
performed in these micro machine
wells and analysis occurring using
a streamlined pipeline that's what
occurs
with iron torrent sequencing
in slide seven i try to show
the processes
in sequence and in the middle slide
in the middle panel
so that's panel 2 the schematic depicts
one of these beads with the nucleic acid
sticking out of it
in which when we flowed a particular
d-oxy trinucleotide
triphosphate hydrogen ion is released
and in three you can see that we're able
to recur
record a current
so essentially this process
the detection systems
recapitulate a small solid-state
uh ph meter and is able to call a base
so
the conversion of
chemical data to digital data
using a physiologic
biochemical reaction
is one of the reasons why this approach
is
rapid a voltage is not
generated if there's not a match between
a base
at its cognitive sequence so no base is
called
and if two similar bases are present
double the
voltage is recorded the beauty of the
system includes the fact that the
direction is detection is direct there's
no scanning
no lights and the simplicity of the
system
also facilitates the readout
the detection of each nucleotide occurs
in seconds
accordingly several million reads
can be undertaken
in a very short period
in slide 8
i show
the genexis platform
it's a self-contained sequencer
a critical ingredient of this entire
system
is the chip which is shown
next to the right of the sequencer
and i would note that these
images are not shown in scale
we have had experience with a multi-lane
gx5 chip multiple panels or assays can
be
performed in a single run using this
chip
the next image shows four strips
colored blue
gray red and yellow
and they are pre-synthesized
and packaged library and template
reagents
and strips which for which there
are slots in the instrument deck
that in a self
instructive or an automated fashion
allow error proof placement of the
strips
onto the instrument
the last component is the onboard
instrument software and analysis
which does not require
an external server
and slide nine i show
the workflow which
starts from
[Music]
a the ability to
compose the assay being run
design the assay being run
and that's what's depicted on the
computer image
on the left there are specific reagents
which come with the
particular essay you have in mind
that the instruments which i've
displayed
in the past slides
a couple of strips and then the
computational analysis
we have had experience using the
uncle mine version
three uh
uncle my comprehensive assay version
which contains
a total of 161 targets i believe
i'll have a little bit more to say about
that
in oncoming slides
in the next slide which is slide number
10
i show that it's critically important
that
the input
nucleic acid is accurately quantified
we have utilized the tape station system
and or the cubit fluorimeter both of
which have performed well in our hands
and our performance of
the alkalmine comprehensive assay v3
on the genexis platform
in slide number 11 i showed the target
list
of ocav3 i had mentioned previously that
there's a total of 161 genes are
targeted loci
of which there are 87 hot spots
copy number variants are called
with 43 genes
51 fusion drivers with their partners
are identified so it doesn't matter what
the partner is if you're fused to one of
these
fusion driver genes that fusion will be
identified
and full exons are interrogated in
48 targets
so once again i show
in slide number 12 the genexis
system
in the middle panel i show the
instrument opened and on the
right panel i show the
instrument deck where
all of the operations occur
at the lower right hand corner of the
image you'll see
a screenshot of the
control panel that indicates where
each reagent goes and this is
really an intuitive interface
which is very instructive in getting
the settings correctly
applied for the instrumentation
so in slide number 13
i show uh sequencing reagents
and consumables which are located
at the bottom of the instrument so
again these pictures are not projected
to scale
but it's important to note that each one
of these
bottles are
easily placed within
the instruments
the sequencing reagents and consumables
are stable
on the instrument for up to two weeks
the conical tubes remain on the
instrument
only replaced by the service engineer
annually
on the top right hand
corner of the slide
i show a compact
cartridge which by design
is space-saving and
permits economical
or efficient use of space
and slide number 14
i have a screenshot of the
user interface for the loading
deck and and this is a really attractive
aspect of this system
the user interface is intuitive and it
facilitates
reagent loading
in designated slots and were you
to load for example
a strip or a reagent
or a coupler or
a chip or even
your pipette tips in an
inappropriate compartment you will get a
flashing signal which would let you know
that that's been done incorrectly
it also intuitively informs
when the appropriate
reagent or device has been deployed
in its appropriate compartment
in slide number 15
we have a screen capture in the middle
showing
the loading of the different strips
again
beyond being intuitive there are
labels that specify where each one of
these strips
go and that is attended
by the graphical uh the user interface
which
informs the user that they've been
appropriately
placed this turns out to be very
advantageous
because the entire suite
of approaches limits the
amount of hand
contact
at least in our hands to 10 minutes or
under on a consistent basis with people
who've only received
minimal training and certainly contrast
dramatically with any of the other
platforms
we've had to use in the clinical
laboratory
in slide 16 i show a screenshot
of the genexis software overview
and its components as
with the experience with other aspects
of this system this is
also intuitive
the first out of four images that as
shown here
just is a cartoon
depicting a sample
the next is one that shows
the run parameters and then next is
results
and then the report that's generated
slide 17 i show an image of an
experiment we did
in our hands using actual clinical
samples
uh you may recall that the gx5 chip
has four lanes
you generally obtain between
eight and 10 million
in our hands reads per lane
and when you
interact with the results
display of
a run you see
when successful all lanes
light up with this very bright red
signal in all the lengths so this is the
desirable result
without doing any deep interrogation of
the data
you'll also see several of the
parameters that
are associated with the run the run
quality results are displayed
and all of this information including
the
percent loading the total number of
bases interrogated
the final number of reads etc
are available for the user to see
i wanted to contrast that experience
with
an unsuccessful run which i show
in slide number 18 where
by comparison to the previous slide
where we saw
very bright red
saturation of each one of the four lanes
here we see um blueish greenish and
uneven distribution and the problem with
this
we learned was
as a result of the inability and this
was
not the instrument at all this was a
user
based problem where we importantly
you'll have quantitative metrics as i
showed you
before the successful run that really
indicate that this was an
unsatisfactory essay i have to
underscore that this is
a highly unusual occurrence in our
experience
and we have had little challenges
working with the instruments and the
system
i show in slide
number 19 an example
of what the results
run characteristics display looks like
without going into detail
there is a display
of the length of the
amplicons and the total number of reads
uniformity and there is a graphical
display of the distribution
of the reads that are generated
so having gained expertise in
running the instrument and we tested
the system using the ocav3
on our acrometrics system which has
a representation for genetic aberrations
across in excess of
50 different genes suffice it to say and
in the interest of time
we obtained a hundred percent
concordance with what those controls
were expected to deliver based on these
results
we were encouraged to continue with
our clinical samples which i described
earlier
these are obviously pressure samples and
easy to deplete and we retain those as
controls for assays that we intend to
carry
forward into clinical implementation
so the study design and this is slide
number 20
we performed the ocav3 panel
which i described previously and
compared with genes present
in the oncoming focus assay
performed on the personal genome
machine you might recall that the
oncoming focus essay
the text 35 hot spots
reports copy number changes for
19 loci or genes
and reports fusions for
23 loci or 23 oncogenic drivers
so the assays were configured as dna and
rna
assays we did them as four pools
anticipated eight million or more reads
per sample
we investigated 24 samples comprising 12
dna and 12 rna
samples the tumor types that were
interrogated were exclusively solid
tumor
the somatic aberrations interrogated
included
single nucleotide variations and
insertion deletions
totaling 11
types copy number variations
were exemplified in six samples and gene
fusions in
12 samples we wanted to interrogate
a range of
mutational variant allele
fractions and these varied from
5 to 93 so the
samples interrogated represented this
range
in the abundance of the variant fraction
and we were interested in examining the
turnaround time
delivered from this system
and slide 22 i show a
summary of the results
so for our
single nucleotide variations of smvs
we observed a 100 concordance between
the genexis
platform delivered results and those
from the pgm
similarly we observed 100 concordance
between the results of the pgm
and the genexis using indel same
for the copy number variations and same
for the gene fusions to assess
the levels of
concordance and correlation between the
abundance of the
variant alleles in our samples we
compared the results
using the pgm and the genexis and that's
displayed in slide number 22
trying to obtain a quantitative
comparison
uh as compared to the qualitative
comparison i
discussed in the previous slide which
was essentially a hundred percent albeit
in a
limited number of samples the
distribution of the frequencies
was very similar
we observed an r squared
correlation coefficient of 0.96 which is
pretty good
and you can see the linear regression
showing the relationship between
the results from the two platforms
and it's critical to
indicate that all of these results were
obtained using the ocav3
gene set within
27 hours
slide number 23 i offer a summary of our
experience
the genexis platform enabled us
to perform an interrogation
of up to 12 samples
in a 27-hour turnaround
with a hundred percent
um concordance with previously
established standards
currently in implementation in the
clinical laboratory
was a single touch point with 10 minutes
of total hands-on time it was 27 hours
from nucleic acid to result
and we have had a chance to
evaluate the on instrument stability
of the reagents and the chip and
in our hands we've been able to
verify that this can last
for two weeks with that i will
uh close this presentation and
thank you for your attention